really nice it's like I dare kill collar
my staff there it was all together quite
delicious the first two tables food
looks amazing needs seasoning first two
tables yeah well my body thankfully
manal and Kelsey are starting to hit
their stride their punjabi main courses
of delicious mutter paneer peas with
Indian curd cheese an amazing spy
stuffed aubergine are going down a storm
ebony dish was really really nice flavor
is full of full of ended in the kitchen
the milestone boys are in full flow
serving their manes of pan fight silver
mullet and pork cooked three ways
texts are very very starters went out
and I was a disaster now the main
courses are going out and it seems to be
a lot more settled and more control
outside more hungry diners are waiting
to the mill of their lives now we should
start them thinking I'll tell you those
tables out okay now there's a queue
outside for poshard experience I don't
want in the freezing cold nor do you
back upstairs tell was relayed and keep
that energy in the dining room please
with just an hour service left the
milestone are starting the second
sitting but upstairs poshard seem to
have lost all urgency leaving hungry
diners waiting outside in the cold at
this rate there won't be enough time
before closing to take an extra sitting
come on come on girl workers all the
same time sorry I'm it's almost like
it's a it's like that everyone's give it
up on come on come on come on unless the
whole family pulls together no one else
will be eating in pacha tonight you know
Cal see you upstairs help clear the
tables pleasure please we've got just
under one hour to go okay so can you go
upstairs and portia table so we get some
more tables under the pot as you guys
I'm telling to do it yeah because you
need help there's listen listen
entertainers you think to do so I'm
asking them to give you a hand and
you'll get an hour going to say no
please go upstairs
I'm clearing tables you can get chippy
with me yeah I'm asking them your mom
get upset and help you you get defensive
I Jean yet because we don't like it to
do those jobs right you okay fine table
don't clear the table yourself with
clearing so she can't punish the table
now she can't be layers no wow yeah he
cracked under pressure cleaning tables
away and trying to set customers that
are standing outside and the cold is
difficult to have that level of
arrogance and get it training my face
like that you know that's that's is cool
but stay calm and deal with it I've step
to Prince estimation problem sector
warden you know he knows exactly what
should do what shouldn't I'm really sad
because I respect that a man to stand up
to him like that not clever Bobby has
finally turned some tables a man now on
Cal she have fixed the problems with
their young starters to the delight a
pro shards new guess I've got an a young
diction it's really spicy and tasty the
spice is not too hot there's justice
right lovely we started [ __ ] we can
finish strong row them round four is
tron running around free strong come on
i can't help but want to approach me and
say sorry but it's not the time
kuber I'm not here to fight with you
yeah I'm here to support a big day tough
day everyone's under [ __ ] pressure
you got 20 minutes left pull it back a
little 20 minutes left pull it back